good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day
yes it's hump day a beautiful beautiful
day also made more beautiful by the fact
that it is september 1st and the weather
is positively gloomy it is so stunning
to behold you know what it is
it's a great day to make chili
it is a great day to make a chili
interesting now i need to
replan my whole day i'm thinking i'm
gonna make a chili okay i mean you are
you talk a big chili talk i just say
when i say i'm making a chili it means
i'm getting the ingredients for ben to
make a chili that works a chili is a
chili doesn't matter who made it wow
that's beautiful thank you we have an
amazing show for you guys today because
here's what's gonna happen first of all
yesterday we podcasted
all day all day long almost five hours
of podcasting we got your toast
yesterday and then we went to meet
michael and lauren bostic of the skinny
confidential his and her podcast and we
recorded their podcast which will be out
soon and they were on our podcast which
is going to be at the end of today's
episode and i'm just so excited for you
guys to hear like honestly i was
thinking about lauren all day me too i
could we talked to them for so long but
i could have talked to them forever i
think they're so interesting they're
such a fabulous couple she's just like
has so much knowledge and information
and she just seems like this person
maybe i don't know if that's true but
she has this confidence that like she
has her [ __ ] life together and like
every time
i i remember feeling this way like the
last time we podcasted together i just
feel like i'm so jealous of like this
assuredness you have like in your life
yeah i feel that and i was just like you
know where you're going yeah and she's
going places she's going back to austin
both of them are oh my god yeah it was a
really good episode uh we talked about
just like literally everything so
that'll be at the end of today's episode
which i'm really excited about yes and
then of course we have the fast five
stories i believe they'll be extremely
fast today and then there was the
abomination atrocity the disgrace
that was the real housewives of new york
season finale where i could not tell you
one thing that happened i couldn't even
recite back to you that's how
forgettable it was okay i will do my
best to remind you but it was so bad i
can't believe that was a season finale
probably the worst season finale we've
ever seen next week isn't even reunion
it's like unseen crap olaf because
season that was so shitty it didn't make
this shitty season but it's making its
own episode because they literally
filmed the reunion last week it's not
ready yet like and if they torture us
with more than one part let's just kill
this horse okay i'm gonna do at least
two parts you know the thing what's the
they shoot dead horses don't they like
leave it alone let bygones be guns and
let's just put this absolute atrocity to
bed and forget it like let's forget it
it was so
so crazy it took me forever to watch it
i was just like on my phone i was just
doing a million other things laundry
anything hanging with brew yeah brew
almost came today the rain that's why
theo didn't come no it's just like then
i gotta pick him up and you know it's a
little stressful as opposed to just
being on autopilot when i come in i know
now you understand me i do but i i miss
that man i'm an amazing man an amazing
man
we also spent yesterday recording more
podcasts we recorded a patreon episode
our final one for august um and we did
an entire book episode so not only did
we go through all the books we've read
this year rate them talk about them
tried not to give too many spoilers but
then we also did a q a just about our
reading habits our favorite books it
ended up being really fun and i think it
was like one of the longest patreon
episodes it was like way over an hour
yeah and we just got carried away with
the literature that's what happens when
you talk about books this is what i've
been saying like if you meet someone at
a party and you guys both read and like
you like colleen hoover
you can talk forever you know let's talk
about that because i kind of wanted to
talk about this in the podcast but we
ran out of time when you talk to someone
about books like at least for me like i
put my best foot forward no no that's
well of course but i'm not like saying
colleen hoover oh i am um but what i was
going to say was like
i find the part of the conversation like
where i recommend books and talk about
the books that i love to be really
interesting but like hearing other
people being like you should read this
book i'm like okay like it's just it's
not that interesting unless you then get
to the point where you both read the
same book then that's like a funny you
know interesting conversation i guess so
if you're just swapping recommendations
back and forth i'm like yeah cool yeah
try this one
yeah obviously you're more passionate
about the books that you've read but if
you are talking to like a reader who you
actually think you have similar taste as
like it could be good to get a
recommendation from them that's how you
discover great books like the best books
i've gotten are recommendations from
people well being like i think you would
like this i get all my recommendations
from you so right and they're all great
and you love every book that you've read
and i love all my new toys like this one
the love island water bottle that i'm
drinking lemon lacroix out of um
you like your water bottle
i do
it's so cool i wish i got one for myself
yeah why didn't you i don't know i was
just like i wasn't even thinking about
me what is so selfless here's what i
need everyone you need to hydrate
everyone is worried about you everyone
thanks guys uh other so new patreon
episode is up all about books and
speaking of books we're recording the
redheads tonight oh my god this is like
my seventh podcast of the week coming up
yeah and it's wednesday and we didn't do
a show monday
um
so
if you read we are the brennans submit
your questions to the redheads book club
at gmail.com and if you haven't read it
and you like to read or you're curious
definitely read this one it was really
good but i spoke to the stature last
night she said she like literally and i
don't know if she was like selling it
extra hard because it was her selection
she was like it was the best book i've
ever [ __ ] read
that sounds like the snatcher yeah like
promoting her own [ __ ] yeah no she gets
like really
when it's someone else's book she has no
time for it yeah that's she's so
counselor so counselor and when it's her
book oh my god it was amazing like
literally like encyclopedia britannica
yeah cuz like because what happened like
the fact that before we were strangers
was a snitches pig and it's the most
popular book like she just rides this
high it's been like a year and a half
yeah i did read that one it was really
good yeah so i'm excited for the redhead
see the girls you know get back together
see what everyone thought
it's never too late to become a redhead
it's such a fabulous community and
one in which i think you all should be
joining and obviously a community of
really kind of well-read obviously
smart you know readers with taste
because they did vote girls wouldn't
drive the crazy beautiful life of an
instagram their monster the second best
redheads book that they read last year
so i mean i was expecting to come in
last i'm not gonna lie so i'm not even
mad at renee yeah and you read that book
and you loved it loved it it was so good
my book was definitely not better than
hers
well my book is really good and it's
available on amazon kindle barnes and
noble all the places international
canada yeah that's right canada
eat some poutine while you read my book
is that
canada yeah yeah poutine
um so what else what's going on that's
it for me really just busy day and then
watched roni so i'm excited to chat
about every ting everything i listened
to more of danta today
then the song 24 banger you heard it
here first okay get i'm thinking radio
play
okay
i'll check it out i didn't listen to
donna this morning i just listened to my
liked songs and it was quite enjoyable
i mean i don't know if this is
i don't know if i've talked about this
on the podcast yet do tell me if i have
but i've recently discovered
not discovered but just realized someone
pointed it out that i am a
very big creature of habit have i told
you this story no i don't think so
because like i whenever i'm eating
dinner alone i always facetime my friend
abe so i like have some company and he's
like what are you eating and i'm always
eating the same thing he's like you're
really creature of habit i'm like you
know what yeah i am like i refuse if i
find one thing i like even if there's
something better out there like i will
stick with the one thing that i like
and now that i know this about myself
i've just become like more aware of it
where is it going with the story i don't
know donda
yes thank you so when it comes to
listening to new music i actually like
have a really hard time i'm like i would
much rather listen to a song from a 35
years ago yeah than even i have not been
able to listen to ben platt yet like it
takes a lot for me unless it's obviously
like taylor swift or like but just like
new music that i know i would like no i
think i'll listen to this old ben platt
album 45 more times no i agree
especially i feel like
when i was younger maybe when i was just
like in a different environment like
working and stuff it was like fun to
listen to new albums as i sat at my desk
yes but now it's like i only have so
much time with music i want to spend it
on the songs that i know that i love and
the ones that like bring me joy like i
don't know if an unknown song is going
to bring me joy yeah i listen to like
half the ben platt album one strong song
stuck out to me the others just like
weren't it wasn't like the last album
like you don't have to worry about you
know having an emotional breakdown well
i listened to it in full blow i was
reading a book and like it all just like
flew by and i didn't even notice the it
was just like a reverie it was so like a
reverie like a reverie what's the dell
song river league river
the river
um okay well then i think we should just
dive in because you know like we are
girls who know what they want yeah i
think we should dive in we can't avoid
these stories any longer trust us we've
tried we tried so without further ado
it is time for the facified stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
oh my turn your turn today's episode is
brought to you by the pill club if
you're on birth control remembering to
take your pill is already enough work
forget going to the doctor in person to
get your prescription and picking it up
from the pharmacy the pill club wants to
help take the work out of taking care of
yourself the pill club is a birth
control subscription prescribed by a
medical professional and delivered
straight to your door they carry over
120 fda approved brands at the pill club
and most brands of birth control are
free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as 9 a
month without insurance
the pill club offers
delivery birth control to your door for
free and discreet packaging and what's
more is that their licensed medical team
is just a text away to give you the best
reproductive health care so skip the
office visit and waiting in line at the
pharmacy and join the pill club
right now when you go to
thepillclub.comtoast
the pill club is offering a 10 donation
to bedsider.org for every morning trust
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org so that's
thepillclub.com toast to get your first
birth control care package and donate to
help more women in need of affordable
birth control reminder it's at the
pillclub.com
toast use that link if you want to make
sure the donation is sent
thank you that's just like a genius
product like why
yeah why isn't that been
well now we know now we know first story
vanderpump rules moms reunite with all
their babies do you see this picture i
did the vanderpump rules stars and new
moms lala ken brittany cartwright sashi
schroeder and sheena shea gather
together with their babies for the first
time for a mom's day out it's seriously
so crazy i know like one it's crazy that
this is the first time we're seeing all
the vanderbabies together i feel like
they've been together but without gina
yeah but then it's just so crazy how all
of this happened at the same time and
it's so crazy like we're not gonna see
any of it and we didn't see any of it
yeah but like looking at this picture i
was just like where are the cameras no
looking at this picture i'm like yeah
that's so cute like oh if only they had
a reality show oh wait they did and not
only did they not film during cove but
half of these people are fired right
exactly but like the kids look like the
exact same age yeah so they really are
all the exact same age yeah and um all
of them are girls except for britney and
jax's son so he has like all these
that's so jack that's so jazzy like his
son is gonna be like the number one guy
in the group he's officially the number
one guy in the group we spoke about this
with lauren and michael on i don't know
if it was our podcast or theirs because
it was so many podcasting hours oh yeah
blended together we spoke about on ours
because we can't differentiate it from
what we spoke on there i wanna i
actually believe it was theirs um no i
think who's uh about vanderpump rules
yeah like she was like so jazzed about
the new season and i'm like what are you
talking about like i'm so nervous like
and i still am like she did not convince
me
i'm feeling jazzed about the new season
i don't know now it's been so much time
that i actually like miss it and i've
watched so much bad reality tv that i'm
like where's the good stuff oh that was
vanderpump rules i know but like now i
feel like we're at this place with
vanderpump rules where the people who
are og's like tom katie tom ariana
sheena like
they
are not going to be acting wild they all
have so much to lose half of them are
parents like it's just not
they're not going to be acting wild so
then you bring in like these young
people who are just so thirsty that like
they're
fake you know danica you know throwing
like it's just so contrived there's no
middle ground that's like that's the
beauty and the curse of a show like
vanderpump rules like at the beginning
they had nothing to [ __ ] lose they
were all just like hungry for fame and
they just turned it around now it's like
they're all celebrities they have homes
to pay for mortgages children they're
not going to be acting crazy and then
people like charlie and danica come in
and see like oh look i could have a big
house like stassi so let me be crazy and
it's just not authentic yes
i don't know where we go from here for
real i know but i feel like
i look forward to watching them try okay
because at least it's something new and
interesting and i'm just so tired of the
crap we've been watching because i'm
just having ptsd from last night's
episode of roni so am i but like i just
don't think we should
be like grouping all these shows
together because we just came off of
love island which was a fabulous reality
show okay
beverly hills is 10 out of 10. beverly
hills is 10 out of 10. but then we also
watch potomac is so good too hot to
handle not great
garbage not great absolute garbage
i don't know what else i watch but i
just feel like reality tv like
it's not doing what it used to do for me
maybe that's you
it's definitely me but it's also the tv
it's both for sure but it's not as bad
as you're making i can recognize that
it's me because like i'm maturing and
evolving and like i just want more isn't
that crazy though because like real
housewives like used to be a show like
for like older women
but now it's like not even good no
i it's me and it's the shows like
everyone can agree that these shows are
just not and if it wasn't for like erica
girardi's
scandal of the year like beverly hills
would be let me ask you a question
let me remember the question hold on
okay
take your time
could you go back to what you were
saying
i've changed the shows have changed
gerardi is when i was like
yes okay so do you remember like most
recent season of orange county was so
atrocious and obviously they went in and
like heather's back and they have all
these new girls
how do you rate that
really bad like low point rock bottom of
oc for what we just witnessed on new
york cause i think new york if oc was
like a two out of ten new york was a
negative 6 000. yeah like now i'm like
oc wasn't even bad yeah there was
something going on oh he was really
really bad but because of like the covet
interruptions like the way that they had
to film but like broadway was being
crazy like they're like
vargas was like sharing her life story
there was something there i agree there
was nothing there last night there was
nothing there last night okay we'll get
to it we're moving on i can't talk about
like just the
decline of reality television i find it
too depressing oh that's crazy next up
mike richards has been fired as the
jeopardy executive producer you're lying
after the host debacle yes richards who
was briefly appointed replacement host
for the late alex trebek has been
officially disqualified as the ep for
both that long time game show and wheel
of fortune
he had stepped down from the coveted
hosting gig last week amid public
outrage and resurfaced sexist comments
however he was expected to remain at the
helm behind the scenes while multiple
guest hosts cycled through on screen
show insiders confirmed on tuesday that
richards was also relieved of his
executive producer duties
okay so i feel like there's two things
that play here one like i feel like part
of the reason why
i would say the reason he got
fired from the hosting job
is because of the comments that
resurfaced on the podcast
and then i would say the reason he
probably got fired from his producing
job is because there was many
allegations that he had like a hostile
work environment and he was like
borderline abusive so for me like that
actually makes sense like i really don't
believe in like firing people because
they said something on a podcast eight
years ago like that's just even and by
the way i know i haven't seen the
comments but i know that they were
deemed anti-semitic and misogynistic
both of which apply to me and i still
just don't think people who should who
said something eight years ago should be
fired like i really don't but if you
actually are actively in real present
time like making it a hostile work
environment like you shouldn't be a
producer
yeah or director whatever his job was
yeah if that's what's happening then yes
i agree the statement said i'm writing
to let you know that mike will no longer
be serving as ep of will of a fortune in
jeopardy effective immediately we had
hoped that when mike stepped down from
the host position at jeopardy it would
have minimized the disruption and
internal difficulties we have all
experienced these last few weeks that
clearly has not happened
there's no mention of a hostile work
environment that he created oh i saw
that like on social media i i
saw something of that vein too but
there's
no mention of stuff like that so to me
this just feels like people were still
mad that people were still mad which is
totally late it wasn't enough that he
lost
the job that he needed to lose his job
too so he went from you know having the
job that a million girls wanted to
literally being unemployed
yeah
damn i just feel like he's one of those
guys who people just don't like
yeah that was the vibe i got from that
article then yeah oh yeah you said that
yeah that's why it's in my head um
damn not a good week for mike richards
no but just crazy and in relation to
kyle and kim
i don't know you should ask him yeah
okay next story kourtney kardashian
shares a bible verse amid scott disick
travis barker drama next story brought
to you by chirp
sure
what a weird coincidence chirp is a
brand dedicated to helping the world
feel good so they can do more of the
stuff that they love in other words
they're all about feel good do more to
do this chirp creates simple innovative
and effective pain relief and prevention
solutions they started with a
revolutionary wheel for back pain but
they're just getting started and if
you've experienced back pain you have
got to experience the chirp that is
something that happened to me during
combat i experienced back pain for the
first time at the young age of 26 and
chirp just came in and really saved the
day they're all about helping people
feel good and do more and back pain can
prevent millions of people from feeling
their best and when they don't feel
their best they're limited to what they
can do chirp can help fix that with
their patent-pending spinal canal and
the three different pressure options to
choose from chirp will help your back
feel better so you can be back to doing
what you love in no time they offer
three different pressure sizes gentle
medium and deep so know your limits
minus gentle bends is deep and they have
a spinal canal to comfort to your spine
as well as the wheel to give your back
four
unique ways to stretch each wheeled
wheel can hold up to 500 pounds and they
can be nestled together for easy travel
to take with you wherever you go so if
you want 10 off their entire site use
promo code toast
gochirp.com is the website g o chirp
c-h-i-r-p go chirp.com promo code toast
for 10 off site wide
thank you i'm sorry i tried to get that
off my chest okay i'm happy for you
i feel better courtney is turning to the
bible after scott allegedly told another
one of her ex-boyfriends that her pda
with travis barker was too much
so she tweeted on tuesday the only thing
that could possibly the only thing she
posted that could possibly be in
reference to this she tweeted
quote john 15 7 if you remain in me and
my words remain in you you may ask
anything you wish and it will be done
for you
see i do like i was inclined to think
that bible verse is obviously going to
be related to this whole drama but i'm
not really seeing this particular
chapter how it's applicable me neither
like basically she's saying because she
believes in god like god is gonna what
like take care of eunice and scott like
i don't know
i don't know i'm not familiar with the
story of john though so maybe the new
testament yes yes so i'm not
maybe i'll miss it
it's possible that it has nothing to do
with eunice she might have been a little
more direct no totally and she should
really like post like those chloe quotes
that like give us more chloe in her
quotes chloe is low-key like so chewy no
it's not she doesn't even try to hide it
remember when her instagram bio for like
15 years was i crave a love so deep the
ocean would be jealous yeah which is
like so something like sheena shea like
has posted and like has tattooed a
tattoo yeah yeah so i don't really see
this bible verse but i did then also see
like amelia gray
posted an instagram and her caption was
dot dot dot and now back to work
which was um when eunice did a follow-up
instagram story yesterday to the
original dm just being like i'm tired of
being the nice guy la la la and now back
to work now it is a common phrase but
emily is so like okay i saw that that
they too said both of them said back to
work and i think they have nothing to do
with each other personally i think it's
that common of a phrase also we didn't
even think about yesterday how like
amelia should be offended
by the whole situation that like scott
is out still thinking still thinking
like still plotting and worrying about
his totally that's actually a really
good point that we totally glazed over
so like now i'm feeling like you know
they had a bad day yesterday
fight you know trouble in paradise they
had a fight yesterday for sure no i feel
like their relationship is so unequal
like she's not allowed to raise concerns
you know what i mean like you don't like
it leave 100 like she a million teenage
girls would kill for this job and like
you have it so you're not allowed to
complain yeah that's like really how i
feel like the conversations go in their
house yeah
it's so that's so i take back what i
said i'm sure it was just a regular day
in the disick gray household
it's so wrong it's so wrong whatever i'm
like happy courtney's living her best
life like venetia altamora yeah and she
like had some delicious pasta last night
i've been i guess like everyone's in
italy right now yeah from venice
true
and they're all posting their pastas and
i'm feeling influenced to have like a
delicious pasta also we were talking
about nutella with
the bostics yesterday they went because
you know she posted on her instagram she
said it's blake lively's favorite
restaurant i didn't know that it's my
favorite restaurant it's so [ __ ] good
but then like hosted her pot let's go
for lunch
yes okay cool patreon oh yes we'll vlog
it do you think they're open for lunch
it's also sonia morgan's favorite
restaurant she said like a quick google
yeah she said that like she lives nearby
and it's like the best date night
restaurant it's so good they cook your
pasta for you like right by the table it
opens at noon oh my god and by the way
it'll be empty for launch you have the
best panel oh my god i can't wait do
they do delivery
no they do digiorno
[Laughter]
good one
no i just feel like i've been in such a
rut recently like all i order is
japanese or chinese the same two places
and
like a couple maybe two weeks ago i was
home alone and i'm like you know what
i'm gonna treat myself and i did take
out mr chow and i had it for lunch the
next day it was such a treat it was a
million dollars but it was a treat you
know not all the time but
i got to find some new places and if
scalia nutella delivered like i would be
finished okay we'll we'll find out when
we go for lunch we'll ask i'm so excited
okay ready for our next story yeah it's
more backlash news ugh you know these
people i can't it's getting crazier and
crazier no like
just wait for it just wait for this one
sarah paulson reveals she regrets
wearing a fat suit for the linda tripp
role in impeachment american crime story
after backlash
sarah paulson is responding to the
criticism surrounding her decision to
play the role of linda tripp in the
upcoming series impeachment which
revolves around the bill clinton monica
lewinsky scandal in order to transform
into linda trip the acclaimed actress
gained 30 pounds wore a nearly five
pound fat suit
wow five pounds
prosthetics no like it weighed five
pounds on her oh prosthetic teeth
prosthetic nose and a wig to emulate
tripp's signature 90s style helmet of
blonde hair
critics believe by taking the role
paulson prevented a worthy actor with
tripp's larger body shape from getting
the role in what will be the third
season of american crime story hitting
um and in an interview with la times she
didn't shy away from the controversy
admitting she that she understands the
criticism about the padded suit she said
it's very hard for me to talk about this
without feeling like i'm making excuses
there's a lot of controversy around
actors in fat suits and i think that
controversy is a legitimate one i don't
and i'm a fat person so i feel like my
opinion on this is more important than
sarah paulson's if sarah paul if i am
playing
okay here's a perfect example
i just been cast in a movie jackie isn't
that exciting so exciting i'm playing
kate moss
they just said i need to lose a little
bit of weight just to be accurate seeing
as how i'm going to be acting as her
right is that great news yeah
who cares yeah you have to look like the
person
right
it's it's not like it's a fictional
story it's really crazy also then okay
so say she was of you know the um the
same body shape as linda tripp but now
she's wearing prosthetic teeth maybe the
role should have gone to an actress with
linda's teeth no honestly i have heard
that the people from the you know why
like the
the yellow teeth community are very
upset and i've also heard that the
people with you know the very slim-nosed
community are upset that she wore a
prosthetic yeah it's disgusting and they
should have let someone with a slim nose
have the roll yeah no and she also had
to wear a wig so it should have been
someone with the existing haircut
because they took away from a worthy
actor with that haircut a wig a
wig i'm done
no this is so you guys sir i hate the
world that we live in too far it's gone
too far i think conversations about
like when people are cast you know
there's finally like a gay role on
disney and they don't give it to like a
gay kid like i understand that like let
the gay kid have the role i really do
but this like for real
or like even when jared leto in that
movie he played someone transgender like
there's no roles for transgender people
let someone transgender play the role i
understand all of that but this
weight it fluctuates so you could be fat
you could be skinny it's so stupid
people lose weight for rolls all the
time they gain weight so what they use a
little special effects
uh and by the way i'm allowed to say
this i'm fat so i just want to say don't
[ __ ] come for me like oh so you're
just allowed to have an opinion yeah
that's true too yeah thanks for wanting
me
it's easy to forget you know like would
do i think i should have had this role
yes
yes am i if no but you're too young and
then the role should have gone to a
jersey actor of linda's age you know you
know
yes that's what i was going to say like
honestly where is linda linda should be
playing linda
no one
and the fact that linda didn't time
travel back in time to look like her
what was she like 40 years old at the
time it's disgusting yeah this is so
stupid i literally like how they really
made her look like her though like okay
so that's linda tripp on the right okay
and that's sarah paulson as linda tripp
oh showing a fat suit who cares yeah i
didn't know that fat suits were um
offensive
yet
no but honestly like if this was me and
i was linda tripp like i would just be
annoyed that like
they're talking about are you guys
thinking of that like wait she's very
fast like right like that's like that
the only person who has the right to be
offended is linda tripp being like
no no like you i'm not happy now
everyone's talking about it no that's
you know what we should really all just
shut the [ __ ] up just for linda's sake
yeah if this was me like in my biopic
and like they're like you went to work
how big was the fact that
how much did she weigh
wait so she had 30
like that would be like yeah that is
[ __ ] rude and embarrassing so leave
linda alone also who's linda in the
story linda is like the woman who was um
beanies like confidant who beanie was
like telling everything about it who
monica was telling everything about her
relationship with the president and
linda was recording it i just have to
say i'm so excited about this show like
it looks so good i just saw a review a
headline that wasn't positive really it
means it's probably good totally yeah
but also just in terms of
this story that we're talking about i
feel like and this is how i felt about
the oj show too
ryan murphy is known
at the end of the show for o.j simpson
and they did side by sides of you know
the actors who played the actual real
person i was floored like everyone did
such a good job of looking and acting
exactly like the person that they were
playing and i feel like that's one of
the best parts of
a ryan murphy show so like okay if he
thought sarah paulson was the best
person for the role should she have not
gotten it because she's not fat like
we're just trying to make a movie here
you know or tv show whatever yeah
sometimes it ain't that serious yeah
but like i understand sarah paul isn't
like she doesn't want to be upsetting
the fat community but sarah like we're
fine okay good i'm glad you let her know
that it takes a lot to offend the fat
community because like we've been
bullied our whole lives but like nothing
can hurt us
sticks and stones i am rubber you are
glue
are you ready for our fizz and vinyl
story which is just like a bit of
nonsense because all the stories are
nonsense is it
yeah this is the only thing that can
make the final story better because it's
the final story
sorry wait this thing sucks okay and
you're you were so off
off you're like literally the guy from
step right but that's how bad it was
dude
it's the final story
[Music]
this story
is not worthy of that song oh no what's
the story a selling sunset star i think
i'm gonna say something about sully i
[ __ ] wish that would be worthy they
have heather ray's engagement party her
bridal shower and all the stars turned
out i don't see christine there no not
everyone was there who wasn't there
other than christine danica
isn't that tanaka on the right
let me see yeah davina
yeah it's divina it says oh my god
davina was there maya
who's this girl that must be a new girl
crechelle
oh amanza
mary
who's the girl on the left emma hernan
and tina oh tina do we know a tina from
shout out so i guess these are the two
new girls tina louise and my and um emma
hernan
so um i'd say this group of women is
like the most best dressed like i know
that's when i saw this picture i was
like
they are so like studying and best
dressed and it's like i'm sure it's like
nice to have friends who show up and
show out for you but like this could be
anyone's bridal shower here yeah except
like heather's only one wearing white
yeah
but i agree like they updated her for
sure because she'll look so cute but
just cuz like everyone looks amazing i'm
really jealous davina looks really
incredible and she's in the worst spot
in the photo she's like all the way at
the end in the foreground yeah
i'm really excited for the new season of
selling sunset i just hope that it's
like i feel like so much happens on
instagram and in the press with the
selling sunset people because they're so
famous and then like if we're watching a
show it's been so long since they filmed
if i'm watching something that happened
like over a year ago like no i want to
see jason and christelle pretend to be
boyfriend or girlfriend like that's what
i'm interested in so if we're not
getting that and we wait till like next
season and then they're both already
like remarried to new people yeah i'll
be annoyed yeah netflix does need to get
better with that with their turnaround
time
i agree i hope it i hope it happens soon
um
but now that i know that people like you
can do love island there's no reason
like
reality shows shouldn't have one week
turnaround times i agree and the
kardashians should have been doing that
forever even like a month yeah like we
were getting two days like literally 36
hours later we were getting episodes
from love island yeah it's really so
crazy it is so crazy so anyways she
celebrated a fig and olive also sounds
delicious on sunday um for the bridal
shower just a few more in newport beach
just a few more months until she ties
the nut to tarik
honestly like they will be insufferable
like during their wedding and all the
pictures so and i feel like this bridal
shower is like the kickoff for like the
next month of them or a few months of
them like thirsting out and i feel like
you know
there's so many festivities you could
have with a wedding there's engagement
party bridal shower bachelor party
bachelorette party not everyone does all
of them i didn't have an engagement
party heather will not let one event go
by yes no she's going to go into every
class sure weekly will be at every
single one of them like
yeah she's going to find events
she's going to convert to judaism so she
could have like a tissue a tissue a
decan and a henna like she's just going
to have a million parties before she
actually gets married and you know what
i feel like christine quinn was
with cupcakes on point in her criticism
of tariq and heather just being like
it's like always something with their
publicist like fake paparazzi and like a
million our cupcake recipe like she was
a hundred percent right like that's
exactly who heather is 100 and it's
boring i agree
and like christine is too busy like
being fabulous pushing her child around
in a louis vuitton stroller to have to
time for these events yeah i just hope
like
it's you know i feel like whenever we
take sides in like you know reality tv
shows like we're always on the losing
side like why is christine the only girl
not there
i don't know maybe she wasn't invited no
i know that's what i'm saying or maybe
she just didn't go but i hope she
doesn't like
really
for the ladies doesn't like just wind up
her becoming irrelevant on the show
right but she could never be around no
she's literally the most interesting to
look at yeah
and now she has this whole new life with
this man
and their baby and their house like i
just want to know more
and like i just like love that she
settled down like so fast it's the
craziest thing
not like you know she's not like heather
like going off like the most famous like
a simple guy
who obviously loves her and i just i
think we could all learn a lot from
christine quinn for a number of reasons
we could yeah
well
from one really good reality show to a
terrible one this is gonna be our tv
recap segment where we recap for this
hopefully second to last time but i feel
like
it'll be a two-part reunion the real
housewives of new york last night was
the season finale thank god and the tv
recap is brought to you by cove no two
migraines are alike and if you
experience migraines you know the
doctors at cove know this too and they
only treat migraines and cove is the
leading online migraine clinic it
specializes in the diagnosis and
treatment of a migraine all from the
comfort of your own home with one
specialist per 80 000 migraine sufferers
in the us cove makes quality care
accessible and affordable
go to
with cove.com and complete an online
consultation designed by leading
neurologists it's as thorough as an
in-person doctor visit then a licensed
doctor will review your migraine history
and recommend a treatment plan
specifically for your needs what's more
is your prescriptions will be delivered
right to your door there's no waiting
for a doctor's appointment no pharmacy
lines just specialized care to help you
control your migraine what's even better
is that cove is super affordable their
doctor's fees and prescriptions are as
little or less than most insurance
co-pays prescriptions start at just ten
dollars a month and with cove you can
have more migraine free days go to with
cove dot com slash toast for 50 off your
first month of medication and free
two-day shipping that's 50 off your
first month of medication and free
two-day shipping with
with cove dot com slash toast toast that
spell w-i-t-h-c-o-v-e
dot com slash toast with cove dot com
slash toast for the ten fifty percent
off and free two day shipping that's a
really good deal
slash toes
[Laughter]
oh really
yeah really it had to be done really you
do it to me every day of course but like
literally like
that's an ad like we have to respect
yeah it's then it's not it's unbalanced
because you're always reading ads so
then i can never come for you and i
usually don't no but i literally talk
like all the time you can make fun of me
whenever you want except the ads no but
usually the talking making fun of is
from the reading the assigned reading
material oh i guess that's true yeah
yeah yeah yeah for sure okay fine that's
fair okay um i'll
i have allow it
my nose will you just tell everyone what
happened on the real houses in new york
oh wow okay yeah sure i'm literally
still struggling with altitude because
i've got that altitude
i've got that altitude so i'm sorry
there's mucus coming down my nose okay
give me a minute we kicked off the last
final and worst episode of roni with pin
the tail on the dubin and harry dubin
calls and everyone's like being so
everyone's being so embarrassing i would
say
um
can you guys can you hear her
nice okay good so you have to hear what
i have to hear um so it was just like
really beyond stupid nothing to say
there then the rest of the episode is
about how they're gonna oh they went to
a greek restaurant and they smashed
plates and they talked about what they
were letting go of i've been saying the
same things that they're gonna let go
for the last 50 years right and estonia
is letting go of asset management and
leah's in love with her ex who knew
plot twist plot twist that was weird i
feel like she was and she wasn't drunk
actually because she's sober like what
where the [ __ ] did that come from i
don't know i mean i guess we never asked
her how she felt about him but i guess
like he she wanted more from him and i
guess he like disappointed her in a lot
of ways and i guess she's kind of
resigned herself to being just a
coherent until her daughter's old enough
to like you know be on her own which is
really sweet but i guess it you know
every once in a while like she said it
gets to her and she really like you know
and that is really sad like she's such
like a fabulous vibrant woman she
deserves love but she doesn't think that
that's what it should be like right now
yeah i just like can't really care okay
i'm just trying to tell you no like i'm
just i'm not
trying my best or compelled by this
story at all
then oh
on the pin the tail of the dubin they
also all took their shirts off i found
that to be like really crazy no no
talk about like
last ditch effort like they think like
oh it's not a good episode let me show
my titties like actually no we're all
good we've seen all of your titties a
million times you know when you're drunk
in turks and caicos that's one thing
that's fine totally acceptable but like
literally in ramona's hampton's house in
the tiny living room with like cameramen
everywhere like like the bright lights
and just like brave it was really it was
shocking to me i mean they all are like
stunning and um
breasts are lovely wonderful breast
breasts aplenty it wasn't about you know
whether the breasts were worthy or not
it was just like what is going on
literally i think honestly like they
were just trying to keep us abreast
i felt very much kept depressed i really
did okay so then after the greek
restaurant they come back to ramona's
house and they're all getting dressed up
for as each other which i have to say
tonight it's like a really funny like
premise and i thought it would have
should have been funnier and but also
it's something that could really go
south but it took the other direction
yes it could but they made sure to like
poke fun at each other but then have
that game where they say nice things
about each other which was smart which
was smart and sweet they chose people
who have the most conflict who dresses
each other which was you know again
could have been scary but it all worked
out ebony and luanne dressed as each
other vershawn and so are you dressed as
each other dressed the best okay best
dress was ramona dressed as leah and
worst dress was leah who dressed as
ramona yeah like
i feel like when when you dress up as
someone like like the worst things you
think about them come out and like
literally like leah can knock it over
this blood plasma thing oh my god she
can't get over it's over a year old
so stupid and the dress like that was a
leah dress that wasn't ramona's never
wear a short dress like that oh my god
with her like butt hanging out like
never she she never has she never would
also ramona doesn't wear makeup what was
with her face makeup there was none no
and then like the karen wig it was just
it was not good it was horrific but
leah's costume ramona's costume as leah
with the leopard and the
gum and the hair it was great it was
great no she was great and she didn't
she was being funny i mean she was
having so much fun she reminded me of me
on halloween were you just like the
person the christmas the personalities
no she's looking in the mirror and she's
like
so i want some [ __ ] like she was being
funny she was really funny but leah was
a huge disappointment the blood plasma
like i need leah to get the q score
reports back and find out that nobody
cares that ramona said she don't need a
buzz plasma but probably was just
getting her antibodies tested and by the
way like i i don't know i wasn't there
at the you know medical center in palm
beach but i'm almost 100 sure that
ramona really for a while thought she
donated blood plasma like thought she
did something when she actually just got
tested for antibodies a hundred percent
i think the same thing too yeah because
ramona's not someone who really like
lies she's not a liar she's just like so
confused yeah yeah so
i was not here for it and also like just
walking around with like an iv drip
it's just like time it was like a little
like
out of touch
i just felt a little out of touch i
don't know let's talk about out of touch
when literally leah was making a speech
at the end that like this country could
take a page out of their book because
they've all spoken about their
differences like
no okay it was annoying because it came
from leah yeah but at the end of it i
kind of understood what she was saying
no i know but like really out of touch
like people should be looking to you
know
no one should okay yes i agree no one
should be like but i agree they've all
worked past their differences and they
all have different backgrounds and they
all have different opinions and they're
having the time of their lives and so it
can be done i don't know if the world
should be looking at them for guidance
but i thought it was a nice moment for
sure and i thought she made a nice point
again the world please do not look at it
um i thought that um it's so easy to do
countess like
just walk around in giovanni like she
makes it so easy but i thought that
uh
luanne did a really good job of ebony
yeah holding court yeah ebony i thought
it was good and the answers that
everyone gave and bershawn and sonia
were great so funny i thought sonia was
great as berson i
feel like bershon could have done more
as sonia yeah i know because he's like
so much sonia's never worn that outfit
in her life no but i think her jacket
was sonia by sonia morgan which is why
roshan thought she like completed the
assignment yeah it wasn't no she was it
was uncompleted
so then they all went around the table
and answered questions like as their
alter ego which showed that they all
understood each other more than the
viewers probably thought i know there
were six women at the table but the
whole episode just really felt like
there were none of like it just felt
like the smallest group of housewives
and like so insignificant and like
another trip to ramona's it was just it
was atrocious and honestly i wish i
could offer some insight people are like
bringing back bethany and joranda but
honestly like i don't know if recycling
old housewives is the move like i think
at some point like the show has to like
shed its skin and move on and like
and find real affluent married people
like not keep recycling the same people
bring bethany back a third time like
would you start fresh maybe
[Music]
i would keep ebony
and i have a very soft spot in my heart
for ramona and she's funny i'm sorry
like i know everyone hates her like she
is [ __ ] funny and she's entertaining
i would keep well that's what the jua
item said that
that they're really shaking things up at
nbc and they're they would only keep
ramona and ebony i feel that like
honestly because you know what sonia her
time has come and you know what so has
luanne like i'm i actually think luanne
would be friend of because nbc owned
some of her cabaret fabulous
sonia's got to go and honestly like
leah's not doing what she thinks she's
doing and also i just don't think leah
leads
an affluent enough life i'm sorry like
this is a show about affluent people and
ramona as she works very hard to keep
that lifestyle ebony has has that
lifestyle like you need people without
lifestyle and the thing is that i think
makes it really hard in certain cities
is like
and i think this is
probably what goes on in new york like
the actual like really rich married
women of new york like do not want to be
on tv like they are private their
husbands don't want to be on tv their
kids don't want to be on tv so i think
that makes it difficult yeah but there
are people who
who would do it yeah and even like these
ladies when we first met them they were
those women luanne yes which is why it's
so crazy how far they've come but when
you think about all the women we've
picked up along the way like none of
them have really been like
that girl like that lifestyle like jules
weinstein like no you know what i mean
like sorry cindy bar shop like no like
when you think i just feel like they
actually have a hard time finding women
who will who have that lifestyle who
will agree to be on tv yeah because when
i think of all the one hit wonders
people kristen take men like who we've
picked up along the way
no
i'm sorry i'd like heather i think i
would bring back heather yeah but not if
leah was there she wouldn't come back
leah should not be there
you think she's not it
but okay she had one amazing season yeah
she's back at zero okay
i i like leah i feel like maybe
you know when you do so well in your
first season you really think you can do
nothing wrong you get like a ego and i
think maybe she just like misread every
situation because she thought there was
like no way that she could be wrong yeah
and maybe this would be like humbling
okay
and then if it's leah ebony and ramona
they should each bring on one friend oh
that's interesting and then also bring
back tinsley i would bring back tinsley
yes
yeah
she wasn't even great when she was like
the most interesting thing about her is
that she left
right and that was like kind of like the
first time i since i met her on tv that
i actually had respect for her yeah i
agree so she's actually going to come
crawling back
on
yeah like no i see the thing is i don't
know what the right me neither
medication for this problem is like
but it's a problem we're seeing in a lot
of franchises because we're it's the
same issue of like changing out of the
original the shows have been on for so
long it's very formulaic
women who
when you when it first started you
didn't know how big it was going to
become like how your life would change
either positively or negatively and it
was just like a fun adventure and there
were so many reality shows at the time
like now you know exactly what to expect
so who's gonna come on
and do anything that's gonna paint them
in a bad light then you just have boring
[ __ ] happening right but if you do find
a person who's willing to do that it
makes a franchise jensha
like she acted even beyond her case like
she acted atrociously yeah and it was
amazing television so there are still
people out there that's true but then
for me like i do get to the point where
it's like i would rather watch boring tv
than watch these toxic people i know
it's actually a really fine line yeah
it's a fine line like dorinda yeah
yeah well
that's that on that there's no recap of
new york next week finally halibut and
and we'll see how many parts the reunion
is yeah and then we have beverly hills
on tonight which always just feels like
a reward for a job well done on having
watched new york completely
um and i also heard background paradise
last night was really good really yeah
but i just couldn't watch two more hours
of television after the three hours it
took me to watch new york so i maybe
i'll watch it but um i'm glad i skipped
a few episodes because it felt like i
don't think anything really major
happened no and i've just been living
like so peacefully in my own mind
knowing that i'm not watching this but
if i do watch it i'm happy to recap it
for you because it seemed like you liked
my recaps like yeah no you didn't i just
i don't want you to feel pressured like
i really read a book read a book
i'm really not into bachelor in paradise
oh wow okay so she's saying no i would
rather you like explain to me like the
woman who loved wallace or whatever that
book was you know what i mean
what was that because woman before
wallace yeah you know what i'm saying
like i i can't really explain how like i
don't how much i don't care about
bachelor in paradise and you know what
i've realized like bachelor in paradise
in terms of relevancy is really going
down because
it used to be like
like on tick tock especially like if
somebody from bathroom paradise or a
bachelor like made a tick tock about
well while the show was airing like
about them like oh a bug flew on my face
like whatever
it would go viral now i keep seeing
really sad contestants like trying to go
by who
demi the only one who's actually doing
like a fair job but she's not even going
crazy viral is tammy because she's like
being funny and self-deprecating but
like i just ca and i don't even
recognize some of these people i just
know that they're a bachelor in paradise
because they're like hashtagging it and
it's like it's not viral like it's
actually really sad that's really sad
that's how you know like less and less
people give a [ __ ] especially people on
tick tock like the young generation like
they don't care also tv recap i spoke a
lot about it on the patreon episode from
last night oh my god so i don't want to
like bore everyone okay but i think it
you need to double dip i watched he's
all that you guys and it was [ __ ]
amazing like addison is an absolute mega
star like she the scenes that she wasn't
in were atrocious and i was like this
movie sucks but she was
sparkle like i can't even she was such a
good actress first of all second of all
she deserves an oscar like it was so
good i loved the element of the
influencer i thought they did a really
good job kind of
explaining and
showcasing how kids are these days in
high school with social media it's
totally true it was just
amazing i did not like the kid who
played cameron her love interest and
honestly he was like the worst [ __ ]
attitude of all time like it's not cool
to do photography like just get a phone
like you're taking pictures of strangers
like that's really invasive and you're
taking pictures of the garbage can yeah
and like honestly
get a cell phone like it's not cool to
like not love like people and cell
phones like i just did not like his vibe
at all yeah but i thought but addison
turned him around yeah and addison was
so cute and sweet and i just really feel
like she's a nice girl because her
character was just like emanating
niceness and so it was actually she's
not like such a you know
experienced actor so she had to play
someone who was kind of similar to her
yeah and it was actually like a hard
sell that she you know had this bet
going and there was like this side of
her that was even that ruthless because
she's just such a sweetie i loved the
ending i loved the homage they paid to
the original movie because her mom was
in it the principal was the guy from the
real world in the original movie they
both wore red dresses there was a
dance-off at the prom it was very subtle
but sweet and i really loved that they
actually cast the mom i thought she was
great and i i just loved every minute of
it yeah but even like when they went to
the party the gatsby themed party and he
gets um he goes in the pool like that's
like when oh yeah in the first movie she
falls in the pool yeah or they push her
in the pool i think she they put they
one girl taylor pushes her yeah and then
in not another teen movie they also pour
bottles of water jackie i literally
confused he's all that with not another
teen movie all the [ __ ] time yeah
there's a lot of movies in there that
make it confusing yeah that they're like
doing satire on and i'm like was that
the original or the satire yeah no it's
cruel intentions bring it on yeah that's
such a good movie such a good movie um
i'm so glad you watched it and that you
liked it and that you had the same
opinions of me including um the stylist
sabotage oh yeah the wardrobe the the
wedge the budget for the wedges was
literally astronomical because it was a
new pair of like
wedgies that ramona singer wears in
cancun like it's just not a thing like
burn all the wedges yeah what did you
think about courtney
oh my god you know i actually thought
she was pretty good like she her role
was bigger than anticipated but still
very small and i thought that you know
she wasn't as cringy i saw her act in
dave and it was really [ __ ] cringy
and i feel like she took a couple
lessons because she was pretty good yeah
she was believable and crazy like how
her like you know influence in the movie
like she was a big part of the storyline
bunny venom yeah
bunny or whatever yeah yeah so cute i
loved it
and i cannot wait to see addison act in
something else i know it was so good you
guys and i have no time for anyone who
thinks otherwise same um but we do have
time for our interview with michael and
lauren bostic it is coming up i hope you
guys enjoy it and we are on their
podcast i believe that drops tomorrow
but don't quote me on that um
but in the meantime just enjoy
this episode and the interview with
lauren and michael we'll see you soon
bye